my question is is if hypothetically
speaking the Islamic state is destroyed
in Iraq and Syria do you think that
would be the high Watermark of Islamic
Jihad I think it would be wonderful if
the Islamic State were destroyed in Iraq
and Syria and it would be a tremendous
blow to the jihadis uh uh the evidence
for that actually comes from Osama bin
Laton himself and Abu musab a zaka you
remember zarka from Iraq al-Qaeda in
Iraq about 10 years ago he was the
notorious leader of al-Qaeda in Iraq he
was killed by an American strike around
2006 and
Zara actually is in a certain sense the
founder of Isis the Islamic State
because al-Qaeda in Iraq became the
Islamic State
he wanted to establish even back then a
caliphate in Iraq and he was in
correspondence with Osama Bin Laden
about it and Osama Bin Laden said yes we
want to caliphate in Iraq but this is
not the right time if we establish it
now if you establish it now the
Americans will come in and destroy it
and it will be a tremendous defeat for
Islam and so Zara he didn't like that
answer and he himself got killed killed
but his group continued and established
in defiance of al-Qaeda which is why
they split he established the caliphate
in Iraq in
2014 and so far he's been proven correct
the Americans did not go in and topple
it and the Very fact of its existence is
considered by Muslims worldwide many
Muslims worldwide as being evidence that
it really is the caliphate because Allah
is blessing and perpetuating it and so
30,000 Muslims from around the world
have gone to Iraq and Syria to join it
now if president Trump actually goes in
and destroys it as he has repeatedly
announced his determination to do then
Osama Bin Laden will be proven right
that the Americans came in and toppled
it and it would be a tremendous defeat
for Islam Allah did not protect his
caliphate and the whole thing came to KN
and so certainly if we went in I don't
think we should engage in the feudal
wilsonian nation building that doomed
the project previously but if we went in
toppled the caliphate and got out it
would be a tremendous setback for the
jihadis even while all the media would
be saying oh this will embolden them
even further we must not do anything to
defend ourselves you notice they always
say you can't do this it'll make them
mad but they're not mad
now you know it's it's it's funny to
look back to where you know where we are
now and I don't know how many years back
when you had regular when we initially
went into Iraq and you heard uh
President Bush and Rumsfeld and Cheney
saying you know we need to do this in
Iraq because if we don't uh you know
Al-Qaeda they want to establish a
caliphate I'm trying to do my George
Bush um but and to the degree to which
the leftwing media just went nuts and
they said this is the new right-wing
scaremonger term you know the caliphate
and there's no such thing as a caliphate
no one's going to establish a caliphate
and um suddenly 2014 we have a caliphate
and I made the joke at the time I said
10 years ago I was predicting that by
now we'll probably have a caliphate uh
10 years ago El Gore was saying by this
time all of the polar ice caps would be
melted we have a califate but what's
what's interesting in terms of the
evolution of um popular thought I guess
is you know so you have this this
mandate within Islamic law and of course
it's being champion by folks like Osama
bin lad and so forth um but you have
this mandate to establish this Islamic
government So when you say what is a
caliphate just think
um religious military political Pope
president General all sort of wrapped up
into one office that being the the calip
and the government his kingdom if you
will being the caliphate well so it's
been viewed I mean if you read a lot
about this primarily as something that
Osama Bin Laden these guys want to set
up well what I've seen in the past few
years now that there is a caliphate is
suddenly you start seeing commentary by
different Western analysts that say you
know something maybe we need to rethink
the concept of the caliphate maybe the
reason the whole Middle East is such a
mess is because of the disolution of the
Ottoman Empire because of the
disillusion of the Ottoman caliphate and
so I think it's pretty inevitable that
we'll see the downfall of the Islamic
State in Iraq and Syria of course there
is the reality that you still have Libya
and the sin and boo Haram and Abu saaf
and all these various groups all over
the world that still are sort of
swearing allegiance to it but what I
suspect long term that we'll see is
we'll see all these well-meaning
far better educated than myself Western
analyst that will say you know something
what we really need what the people have
revealed is that they do desire a
caliphate but what we need is a much
more moderate uh modern Progressive
caliphate maybe something that would be
led by the Turks you know a much more
cultured version of Islam and I think
we'll increasingly see folks that will
say yes that's what will restore order
to the Middle East and so you know it's
easy for the world to look at Isis and
go this is horrible but when you start
presenting sort of a more moderate
version of it I think that's in in the
longer term that's actually the greater
danger um because then you give the that
Collective power to uh one one leader
and you've got so many different more
moderate uh so-called you know
uh moderate Nations throughout the Earth
coming under the you know and I think
prophetically there's probably a pretty
solid case for that as well so I don't
know if that necessarily answered part
of what you were asking but long term
that's what I suspect that we'll see
this is also closer to fruition than
many people realize
because
turkey uh is ruled by re T erdogan the
president who was previously prime
minister he's been in power for very
long time and he has made it abundantly
clear in numerous ways that he is no uh
fan of secularism of the calist
philosophy that has been in power in
Turkey since the 1920s and he believes
in Islamic government he has been
systematically dismantling cism and
reestablishing Islamic government in
Turkey it is widely believed with very
good reason that the coup attempt
against him a few months ago was
actually staged by him in in order to
give him a pretext to round up the
remaining enemies that he has and to
consolidate his power entirely he's also
been frequently accused not without
reason of wanting to reestablish the
ottoman caliphate and has frequently
been criticized again not without reason
for not acting even though he's a NATO
Ally of the United States against Isis
now why would he not want to move
against the Islamic State if you
consider it doesn't take very long to
figure it out if he really wants to
reestablish the caliphate but put it
back in Istanbul where it was under the
Ottomans and here is this group in Syria
fighting against Bashar Assad who he
hates because Assad is an alawite and
not a legitimate Muslim in his eyes and
the Kurds who he hates because they want
their independent state and he wants to
reestablish the Ottoman
Empire they're fighting against his
enemies they're doing his job for him
they're pulling his chestnuts out of the
fire as they used to say so he is hoping
it seems pretty clear to me to
ultimately co-opt the gains that they
have
made and reestablish his own rule in
those areas as he attempts to co-opt
their caliphate and move it to
Istanbul please sure in fact let me just
add something to that real quick before
um and this will be the interesting
factor with regard to Trump is to say it
you know there's obviously many things
that he's doing that are fantastic but
you know essentially what Robert just
presented the case for is that there is
some wisdom in a restrictive immigration
policy but of course then if that's the
case then why not every Islamic nation
and I don't suspect that we'll see any
immigration restrictions from Saudi
Arabia um or turkey and so forth and so
the question with regard to Trump is
will he maintain the status quo um you
know the approach that we've been in
terms of relating to Turkey which is an
emerging fascist nationalist imperialist
dictatorship are we going to continue to
relate to them as though this is still
the
old secular Bridge nation and so forth
and what will his relationship be with a
IES and that's critical um so yes
there's definitely
some good things that are being done in
the political realm but there's also a
lot that's still continuing as it has
been for the past 20 years and one one
other thing too I'm sorry but one
extraordinary thing about President
Trump is that he uh he keeps saying
these things that indicate that he has
some real
insight when you wouldn't never expect
it I don't mean any insult to the man
but you know he's been a reality TV host
and he's a billionaire and then he says
NATO is
Obsolete and everybody was all upset and
said why we need NATO he's such an idiot
and I thought that's one of the smartest
things he ever said NATO is obsolete it
was formed to fight the Cold War the
cold War's over the walls down so no
more Soviet
Union so NATO needs to be recast to
fight what we're really in now and that
would mean a realignment that would mean
understanding turkey is not on our side
they are not going to help us against
the Jihad they have consistently refused
to help us against the Islamic State for
the reasons I just explained and for
others as well and so we need a global
alliance against the Jihad I hope he
follows through on that and doesn't
allow himself to be intimidated by the
uh experts who know so much more all
about everything than he does and will
tell him that we really need NATO we
don't it's over it's time for a global
counter Jihad Alliance that was actually
possible a few years back Putin asked
Obama to fight with him against Isis we
could ally with Russia against Isis and
everybody was appalled Putin's a monster
the Ukraine the Crimea he's terrible
yeah we fought alongside Stalin to
defeat Hitler Putin is not as bad as
Stalin we can't fight alongside Putin
against the Jihad that's the kind of
Alliance that we need to pursue
now so you mentioned that the the
election of President Donald Trump was
kind of like the coming out of the cave
if in France they elected Marine Le Pen
would you think that would be like the
coming out of the cave for for Europe oh
yeah you know I think uh what was the
term for the vile and filthy French
would that be the equivalent spiteful
and filthy French yes I've known many um
sorry I haven't really um
the thing about Europe right now is that
it's on the brink of a massive
disengagement from Plato's
Cave Europe could go either way right
now people have asked me for years is
Europe done for Europe's done for isn't
it and I would always quote the sage
philosopher Yogi Bara it ain't over till
it's over there are not Islamic States
in Europe now and maybe there never will
be if Leen is elected in France and VOR
is elected in the Netherlands
and the Sweden Democrats continue to
grow as rapidly as they've been growing
in
Sweden there will be tremendous upheaval
to turn this around but it could still
be turned
around the the fact is that we have not
yet begun to fight and the situation is
very Advanced people don't realize how
bad it is really and so it's going to be
a very difficult fight but even the fact
that we're talking about the possibility
I remember talking to builders a few
years ago and saying you ought to be
Prime Minister I hope you be prime
minister one day and he said oh I'll
never be prime minister uh and he
explained to me in great detail how you
have to have a coalition and he'll never
have enough he might actually win enough
seats to be able to have a majority of
by himself as the situation grows more
dire and so uh what seemed impossible
just a few years ago is now on the
horizon it's very wonderful time to be
alive Trump actually sort of paved the
way for Builders um because I didn't
think before Trump got elected that
someone with hair like that could ever
get in and now yes possible this is the
weird hair era for world
leaders don't typically need a
microphone but just to counter the bush
and Cheney went to Iraq much more
because of weapons of mass destruction
than they did the caliphate however my
question to you is Germany is the
financial backbone of Europe
and the the the the producer of
Technology actually produced things how
long can Germany
last in under
Merkel as my brother in Germany
says Merkel in took the immigrants out
of compassion and they didn't spread
across the world and it I tell trust me
that just like vibrates me but how long
can Germany
last under Merkel under Merkel Germany's
Dead uh Merkel is the best Chancellor
Germany's had since Adolf Hitler if you
want Germany
destroyed Hitler ultimately was he he he
was known he he campaigned he uh ruled
as the savior of Germany but he was
actually the destroyer of Germany and
Merkel is the second destroy destroyer
of Germany Germany seems to have some
sort of strange Death Wish and maybe it
is penance for all the evil that Hitler
brought to the world I don't know but
Merkel is has shown no indication of
reversing her stand and so she's
bringing in massive numbers of people
who believe that Islamic government is
better than secular government and who
believe that Infidel women exist for
their sexual use and who believe that
non-muslim ought to be wared against and
subjugated there's no way that Germany
is not going to have a future full of
blood as a result but here again if she
loses then they may have a
shot um you can probably tell by my
accent I'm not from round here and
Mississippi I
know yes you city right yeah um and I
know that you know a lot about Great
Britain
and um I'm not allowed in there you know
no I know um I really love my country
and um grew up in an area which is now
um a very Islamic area and
um I just wonder you said that there's
hope for Europe Mainland Europe but I
wonder if you think there is that hope
too for Great Britain well you know
since we're speaking about uh accents
and geography I was was actually born in
the great state of South Carolina you
might not know what to look at me but
it's true
and the state motto of South Carolina is
Doom Spiro Sparrow while I breathe I
hope and I think there's a lot of wisdom
in that while I breathe I hope I'm still
here so things could get
better and as long as there are free
people in Britain and I know there must
be a few then things could change but
it's the same situation actually in
Britain as it is in
Germany if terresa May remains prime
minister Britain is going to be dead as
a free Society in a very short time if
the conservatives are decisively
repudiated along with the
Liberals and ukip becomes the leadership
then Britain has a
chance but that doesn't even appear to
be close to on the horizon but let me
tell you what's happening in Britain
it's not just you're right I was there
in 2009 last and I was walking around
some areas of London I could have been
in Karachi there was just no sign that
it was an English place and it's only
been worse it's only gotten worse since
then and the thing is I was as I have
now mentioned several times I was banned
from Britain for actually saying the
home office letter signed by Teresa may
she was the UK home office uh secretary
at the time she said that I said Islam
has a doctrine of warfare against
unbelievers and this is the h crime that
I'm too criminal to be allowed in
Britain now she actually reiterated this
recently and she said that uh she was
very proud she was boasting in a very
recent speech uh while she's been since
she's been prime minister she said that
she kept out Pamela Geller and Robert
Spencer from Great Britain just as she
acted against Abu Hamza and Abu katada
well Abu Hamza is the fellow I was
explaining to you before with the hooks
for hands who who was an active Jihad
preacher who would preach Warfare
against unbelievers and is in prison now
for trying to set up an Al-Qaeda camp in
the United States she's likening me to
him I'm just a writer I just type all
day I have never called for any violence
or Justified any violence or anything of
the kind I want to preserve free
Societies in which there is
non-establishment of religion I believe
that that's a genius element of the US
Constitution to have no established
religion I know in England they in in
Great Britain in general there's an
established religion that receives State
funding in the United States of course
we do not have that and now some of you
might think well I wish there were an
established religion I hope you don't
think that because the fact is that
however much we may know that what we
believe is true there are some people
who are never going to be convinced that
is an unfortunate fact of life and they
live among us that is another fact of
life so you have a two choices you have
a society in which people who differ
fundamentally on the big questions live
together in peace without one trying to
gain hegemony over the other or you have
one system one point of view that's
Paramount and the other people who do
not subscribe to it are deprived of
certain rights as a result of its being
Paramount now I know there are
tremendous problems with secularism and
there is a real war against Christianity
certainly in the United States and in
Europe but uh that's really a separate
question uh the idea of
non-establishment I think is the
absolute prerequisite to a peaceful
Society in a pluralistic age in which
people are going to differ on
fundamental questions now all that said
Teresa may Likens critics of Islamic
Jihad to Jihad killers and not only that
but while she said that she's bringing
in Jihad preachers to Britain I have a
list of them on my website
jihadwatch.org you can find it if you
look at the search for the articles in
the UK a whole list of people who have
Justified murder called for murder there
were a couple of jihad preachers from
Pakistan in Pakistan they have blasphemy
laws that are used to victimize
Christians on a large scale and there
was a politician who was against the
blasphemy laws he was assassinated by a
Muslim and the Muslim has become a big
hero these two preachers there's a
mosque named after him and these two
preachers were praising him they were
not only allowed into Britain for
praising this murderer and calling for
murder of blasphemers but they were
welcomed at the airport by the
Archbishop of
Canterbury and that's just one example
these guys stream in all the time this
is going to be the death of Britain that
they do not move against Jihad and they
actually move energetically against
people who are foes of
jihad um Tommy Robinson the the English
Defense League I'm not justifying
everything he did with the edl and I I
don't even want to get into it but the
fact is that all he was trying to do as
a workingclass Englishman was stand up
for England as such and Britain in
general and to defend it against
islamization and he has been viciously
persecuted by the British government
put in jail unjustly he came to speak at
one of our events in 2012 and they
jailed him they put him in solitary
confinement for months and they arrest
him for nothing even now he was out with
his family in a restaurant and they came
and took him away for nothing now this
kind of thing they're actively trying to
discourage resistance to Jihad Terror
that means they're get they're going to
get more Jihad Terror I don't see how
Britain can survive unless the whole
political establishment is swept out
I I just think that we're slightly
different to the rest of Europe because
of our Colonial history and and that's
been our immigration since the late
1950s and um and and I think really I
can see why the government do what they
do because we're all kind of in the
short term we're all okay but in the
long term it's in the long term where I
actually I'm sorry but find that not
little hope really in the long term of
the future future there's always the UK
because um of the sheer numbers of
people you understand also the freedom
of
speech is the foundation of a free
Society you don't have a free Society if
you're not allowed to criticize some
individual or group then that individual
or group can do whatever he wants so a
free a free Society depends on the
freedom of speech resistance to a tyrant
depends on the freedom of speech but
Islamic law forbids critic ISM of Islam
and the British government energetically
fights against criticism of Islam and
people who are against Jihad Terror and
so they are actively aiding in the
establishment of a Sharia provision in
the UK and once that one's fully
established as it very nearly is now
then all the rest will follow
eventually can I do you mind if I if I
add just a couple things real quick
CBS I think uh there's a couple things
here I want to say it's important to
make some clear distinctions between
what's taking place in Europe obviously
and what's taking place here in the
United States because it's easy for
folks um you know to watch what's
unfolding in Europe and imagine that
it's actually happening here and you
know we're 20 years behind Europe in a
lot of ways um but what we have is
really multiple merging trends at one
time it's it's really The Perfect Storm
there's sort of philosophical
ideological
Trends um and then of course demographic
Trends and immigration Trends and just
all sorts of things are happening at one
time
so first of all you have the issue uh
European socialism obviously is a fairly
different model than what we have here
and so in a lot of ways you know it is a
pzi scheme socialism requires this this
um ever expanding youth population to
prop up the Aging European you know
retirees and um so that demands
immigration well of course Europe sits
on top of North Africa you know
overwhelmingly Muslim and then of course
so most of the immigrants are coming
from the Middle East and North Africa of
course the United States is in a very
different situation you know our our
immigrants are largely Latino Catholics
it's a very different situation that we
you know we just need to acknowledge um
the salvation of this country is uh
Catholic Mexico you're just kidding but
um there's some truth to that but um but
of course we don't rely on we we're you
know obviously not quite as social
socialist um in our sort of economic
system but there's also the trend of the
fact that you know we're now a couple
Generations into of having been
brainwashed and just our our ability to
think critically and just think
rationally has just been completely
hamstrung um through moral cultural
relativity etc etc and you have within
Islam Muslims you know throughout the
Quran they're repeatedly told you are
the best of people you have the best
Prophet you know you have the best book
etc etc and you know you're the best the
best the best and they have this
incredible sense of cultural confidence
and and even superiority and they're
colliding with a people who have this
incredible lack of value in in their
Collective history and and so on and so
forth and you know even on top of that
that Christian civilization is largely
founded I mean Western Civilization is
largely founded on judeo-christianity
and the bibl you know biblical faith and
thus we are largely a confessional
people even the most staunch secularist
in the United States there there's a
value for confessing our weaknesses
confessing our sins Etc even to a fault
to where we don't have any sense of
appreciation for the principles that you
know in the American Constitution
equality civil liberties Freedom all of
these things and so here we have these
people you know this this these people
we have a complete lack of cultural
confidence so first of all we need to
regain a sense of cultural superiority
now the problem with that is as soon as
you use the word superiority everyone
hears racial superiority we've been
brainwashed to hear that has nothing to
do with race it has to do with saying
that the principles established yes C we
have fallen short but we we aspire to
these principles of again equality civil
liberties they are superior to the
principles in Islamic law you know the
value the testimony of a woman is only
half as good of a man etc etc etc in
order to establish that a woman was
raped there must have been two male
witnesses that actually witnessed I mean
you know it's just it's ludicrous so
first of all there's just a general
sense of Co and I don't have a lot of
confidence that we're going to regain
that I I really don't but beyond that
there's the issue of the Gospel there's
the issue of the church and the question
is okay so you know you look at for
instance uh England and I don't know the
exact numbers of of Muslim Muslims now
that are in England how many
millions oh um well I think I'm not sure
really but it's um large sections what
the toal population of the UK uh it's
probably about 80 million okay about 80
million so it's a small percentage
but um you know they're very very um
focused on certain cities and towns ands
and so forth so so now in a way that you
don't you don't see anywhere like uh
here right and everybody actually gets
on pretty well which is in a way for the
long term part of the problem because
everything's okay because you know
Society in in the UK works very hard to
make sure that you know we we all get on
it's not like France or um our our um
immigrants don't come from North Africa
it's the Indian subcontinent it's
slightly different well very different
actually so at the moment it's okay
people are trading water very hard to
try to make sure it is but I guess I
just think in the long term because of
the sheer
numbers and the fact that they're
they're the ones that are you know
really having lots of children right so
of course the adage the future belongs
to those who show up for it um you know
and again you've got your stereotypical
50-year-old guy from Germany to living
at home with Mom and you know on the W
weekend it's not he's not having
children it's disco disco and you know
whatnot and you know and then you
combine that with the immigration pop
you know they're exploding again so
these demographic shifts happen rapidly
but here's what I was going to say which
is you know that can happen fast in 20
years you know the entire it can look
radically different but you look at the
numbers and so if you get roughly 80
million in the UK there are
approximately 3 or 4,000 converts to
Christianity from among the Muslim
population 3 or 4 thousand that's these
are some estimates that I've seen you've
got a couple hundred thousand converts
to Islam among
Brits so I want to think about this
here's a largely what's supposed to be a
Christian Nation you've got 80 million
you've got this little teeny percentage
of of Muslim immigrants that come in and
they've converted a couple hundred
thousand Brits and we the Brits have
converted uh 3 or 4 thousand the church
doesn't truly have confidence in the
message that we are the ambassadors and
stewards of so I think you know when we
say because it's very easy to hear all
of this and leave and go crap you know
like what did we do that for that was
depressing but I have
confidence in the gospel I have
confidence that the message that we are
stewards of is the most
emotionally spiritually just logically
Superior message that mankind is ever
known if the church WIll reclaim a sense
of confidence in that message Islam is
ridiculous but they have such incredible
confidence in their message and because
of that confidence that you know a lot
of Christians are terrified to talk to
Muslims and yet we have the words of
life that can save them that ultimately
they're crying out for they're why why
are they blowing them because they're
crying out to the god who's not there
who never reveals himself he's not there
and so behind all of this we do we can't
leave tonight with being you know just
depressed and go man that's just that
was a that was dark because there is
hope but the hope is ultimately in
Revival and we you know we we can it all
of the political Solutions and the
political things that need to change
that's all very legitimate um but much
more than that we need a spiritual
Revolution and there is some Hope by the
way you know there there's some move
among the immigrants I mean you know to
a degree Satan thought hey with Isis I'm
going to do my thing and a lot of
Muslims are looking at this and going
this is gross and you know there's the
atheist movement and so forth but there
are many Muslims that are coming to
Faith but the numbers are not
significant enough yet to cause a
massive you know cultural shift um but
it's not going to happen if we don't
open our mouths and start preaching the
gospel and reclaim that missionary Zeal
of the early
church this is very important and I hate
to inject another note of lack of Hope
after that very these very important
words but I do think it's important at
the same time to know where we are and
to face it as as Grim as it is and then
we can begin to move to where we need to
be uh and so when you were saying
everything is okay I just wanted to
remind people that everything is only
okay because people are afraid to speak
and in Britain everything is not okay in
Britain in one town
Ram uh there were 1,400 girls who were
brutalized and victimized by Muslim rape
gangs who were basing their actions on
the teachings of the Quran I outlined
earlier and that's just one town this
happened all over Britain and
authorities knew about it and covered it
up because they were afraid to appear
racist and
islamophobic now that is a society in
the midst of committing suicide that
point of view has to be eradicated it
goes exactly with what Joel's saying if
we recovered a sense of of cultural
confidence and took up again the fact
that this is spiritual warfare then we
would challenge those authorities and
say this is an Abomination that you are
allowing to happen and replace those
authorities with authorities who are
willing to call it what it is and take
action against it
accordingly I was wondering if you could
speak to the obvious and growing
Alliance of Islam and the American
left and where that's going to end up I
mean they're
so diametrically different in their true
core I can only imagine it's going to
explode or they're going to kill each
other or
I think actually on the contrary it's a
very happy marriage that will
last and the reason why I think that is
because both Islam and leftism are
totalitarian in nature at their
core uh you say well not the American
left yeah the American left because the
American left you know they walk around
with Chay t-shirts who was
Chay Chay was a bloodthirsty and brutal
to totalitarian killer in service of a
Communist Regime that went to war
against its own people and they think
he's a hero and of course yeah most of
those Stoners who are walking around
with cha t-shirts have no idea who he is
they just know it's the cool shirt to
wear now man cuz they also have the free
to bed stickers yes yes free to bed I'll
take it
but the reality is
underneath when ever the left has been
in power when it IT preaches Brotherhood
and equality and from each according to
his ability and to each according to its
needs to his needs but when it gets into
power it enforces that by means of a
procrustean bed I'm full this is ancient
Greek Knight I started with Plato and
now we're at procrustes do you remember
procrustes he was a tyrant and he would
torture his enemies he had a bed and he
would put you make you lie down on his
bed and if the bed was too short for you
he would cut off what your legs until
you fit and if the bed was too long for
you he would stretch you until you fit
we were
safe well we'll be stretched to death
but uh he made everybody fit he made
everybody the same size that is the
Communist ethos that they will establish
an equal and just society in which
nobody is Rich and nobody is poor
everybody's equal and they will cut off
all the limbs that don't fit they will
torture those and kill those who get out
of
line from each according to his ability
and to each according to his needs is
actually a very frightening statement if
you think about it because it means that
the people who work are going to be
stolen from to pay for the people who
don't which is of course What's
Happening Here on a massive scale and
that can ultimately only be done by
violence and so they are always violent
totalitarian societies that enslave and
brutalize their own people and that's
the left now what is Sharia Islamic law
Islamic law is as Joel said the Quran
says you are the best of people you know
where it says that it says that in
chapter 3: 110 and it says you are the
best of people on Earth and then it goes
on to say enjoining what is right and
forbidding what is wrong you were the
best of people precisely because you
know what's right and wrong and they
don't and so it's the muslim's job to
tell us what's right and wrong now their
vision of what's right and wrong as we
have abundantly explored tonight is
abominable it's
evil and so it and it consists of the
same kind of thing that the left does a
procrustean bed a reign of terror Sharia
is a slow motion reign of terror they
will establish the perfect Society of
the best of people and if you get out of
line you'll be stoned to death you'll be
thrown off a building you'll be beheaded
you're hand will be cut off it's a reign
of terror it's just like what the left
does so they are both violent tot
totalitarians trying to establish the
utopian society by means of
violence and so they're I think they're
blood brothers and their kin and they
see that and that's why they love each
other also far simpler answer they both
hate America they both hate America they
hate Judaism they hate Christianity they
want to destroy judeo-christian
civilization and so they see in Islam
Christianity chrom's ancient
enemy and they think my friend the enemy
of my enemy is my
friend now what about the fact that you
have these people who are homosexuals
and all these other things that Islam
says put them to death I think that the
left in that sense does not realize what
they're getting into because leftist
atheists don't understand the religious
impulse of any kind they have contempt
for it they have contempt for
Christianity and Christians they think
they are easily LED remember even the
Washington Post said you years ago
famously that Christians are poorly
educated and easily LED and this is what
they think of us
so they think of of any religionist in
the same way they're going to be able to
take care of them once they destroy the
West once they destroy Christianity once
they destroy America they'll deal with
these silly religionists with their
funny hats but the silly religionists
with their funny hats are going to have
a few surprises in store for them at
that time Ki had Communists in his
Alliance when he established the Islamic
Republic of Iran and they all ultimately
were killed and the El I think will
ultimately find that out but even to
their death it will be a happy marriage
as the blade slices through their neck
they will be saying I was never
racist yeah I have a more interpersonal
question and um you I think there's
different Muslims some are more cultural
and some are more religious um for those
of us like myself we've studied the
Quran and the Hadith and the life of the
prophet and certain number of books that
you've written um and so I have a basis
to understand Islam and all that so what
do you from both of you what do you
think are the two best say entry points
to get say a cultural less religious
Muslim to think about and question their
faith and what are say two different of
the best entry points to get a more
religious Muslim to think about and
question their faith because I would
guess there are certain Muslims that are
just cultural and they don't even know I
mean they probably just they don't read
the the Quran or if they do it's the 7th
Century Arabic so they don't know what's
in it so I think there's two different
ways to approach those so I was just
wondering from both of you how do you
approach those two different types the
best
way so I'm going to go back to uh
something I said this morning which is
we are uniquely called to be uh a people
of you the people of the Cross when um
those was it 21 21 or 22 Martyrs on the
Libyan Beach were killed the video that
Isis made was a message to the people of
the cross I thought that was sort of a
Divine slip if you
will you know Jesus said it the Apostle
uh Peter said I think Paul I think all
three of them said it but they made
reference to don't be like the Gentiles
for they lorded over one another there's
a very natural propensity among carnal
mankind to Lord it over one another you
know politicians get in power they every
position of authority in the earth is
intended to be a position of servant
leadership people get in positions of
power and they exploit those under them
they claw their way to the top of the
pyramid um until they are the most
significant Amway distributor in the
whole tri-state area you know whatever
you name it they're everyone put at the
top of the pyramid and Jesus says don't
be like the
unbelievers he says imitate me be a
servant and so we are uniquely called to
be a PE and that's what the cross is is
God himself the creator of everything
put himself at the bottom of the line
and when Muslims en encounter people who
genuinely model a culture of the Cross
now you have Middle Eastern hospitality
and all of those things I I don't want
to paint you know Islamic culture is
just purely bad there's a lot of Beauty
in in some of those things but what they
can't grasp is J genuine sacrificial
love and when you whenever you meet
Muslims that have come to Faith they
always say you know you would think well
I read the Bible and it just blew me
away and you know sometimes you hear
that but the most consistent reason
Muslims say this is what led me to
become a Christian as they go a
Christian loved me and so you know we
can simplify saying be being a p a
culture of the Cross is being people who
are truly loving um but that's almost
always going to be the thing that opens
the door of any human heart and cause
them to start questioning uh all of
these things so that would be probably
this you know then yes give them a Bible
pray for them lay hands on them attend
to their needs and all those things but
certainly neglecting them is not going
to be the best inroad
right I would add uh also and this is
very delicate very uh difficult and you
have to do it very carefully because
remember that
preaching prizing
in Islamic law prosti another religion
is a death penalty offense now a Muslim
is not going to kill you in the United
States for talking to him about Jesus uh
but you do need to be very careful to be
uh respectful of the Quran and Islam
doesn't mean you have to praise it in
some spirous way but not uh be insulting
about it certainly and yet at the same
time I think it's very important to try
to create some cognitive dissonance and
this is to many Muslims converting to
Christianity uh
because the questioner was right that
there are many Muslims who have no idea
what's in the Quran this is because you
have to pray in Arabic if you were to
convert to Islam tomorrow which I
actually don't recommend then you would
have to you wouldn't be able to pray
right away you'd have to pray in Arabic
if you wanted to go to the mosque that
is and do the five daily prayers you'd
have to learn at least to mouth the
syllables because you have to pray Allah
does not listen to prayers in that are
not in Arabic and you read the Quran in
Arabic it's not even the Quran if it's
not in Arabic so I had a Pakistani
Muslim tell me and he was quite serious
people always think this is a joke but
it was he was completely serious he said
I'm very proud of my religion and I've
memorized almost all of the Quran and
one day I intend to get one of those
translations and find out what it
means he was going in and they in in
Pakistan you go to a madrasa as a child
and you learn you might memorize the
whole Quran and have no idea what it's
saying you're just memorizing Arabic
syllables and so to
introduce these people whether culture
or religious uh to introduce Muslims to
some of the things in the Quran just ask
questions say uh for example that in the
Quran Jesus is born of a virgin there's
no mention of Muhammad being born of a
virgin in the Quran or in Islamic
tradition in the Hadith Islamic uh
tradition the words and deeds of
Muhammad it is Muhammad says that Jesus
will return at the end of the world he
will return and make war against
Christianity and break the cross but the
point here is is that Jesus is the one
returning not
Muhammad and
the Quran calls Jesus the word of God
and it says that it just means by this
that Allah said be and he is in other
words he wasn't born in the ordinary way
he's born of a virgin but why is Jesus
the word of God and not
Muhammad and Muhammad in another Hadith
says that Jesus and his mother were the
only sinless people now Muhammad is
essentially treated as sinless in Islam
but even the Quran in chapter 80: 1 to5
speaks about an incident where he was
rude to a poor man who came to him
because he was talking to the rich only
and he's rebuked by Allah for it and so
Muhammad is strictly speaking not
sinless but Jesus is in
Islam and so why is that why is Jesus
born B of A Virgin and the word of God
and sinless and going to return at the
end of the world and Muhammad is none of
those things and yet is a greater
Prophet the real answer is is because
the compilers of the Quran took some
pieces of Christianity and put it in
their mix without really understanding
them and so they left by Divine
Providence apparently they left some
Clues and hints in there in this book
that teaches very great evils they left
some Clues and hints to the fact that
Jesus is actually something very much
greater than a prophet and you can ask
why is it that he has all these things
and I I have known ex-muslims who are
Christians who said that they started to
wonder about that and it made them want
to read the New Testament and then one
thing led to another the other one is
the uh Injustice of
Allah Allah actually says in the
Quran if we had willed he always refers
to himself in the Royal we if we had
willed we could
have saved all men brought all men to
the truth but instead we will fill hell
with Gins these Spirit beings and
men so that's just the opposite of God
Wills all wants all men to be saved and
come to the knowledge of the truth Allah
does not want all men to be saved and
come to the knowledge of the truth as a
matter of fact he has deliberately
misled some people in order to torture
them
eternally now that's a monster that's
not a just God by any means and I
remember once when I was in college
uh this is way back in prehistory I know
but they I was talking to a Muslim and I
just asked him that because I really
couldn't figure it out say you say that
Allah is compassionate and merciful
right it says that at the beginning of
113 of the 114 chapters of the Quran and
he's just right and yet he's going to
fill hell with Gins and men and it says
Allah leads astray Those whom he wills
and guides Those whom he Wills Allah
leads people astray he actually misleads
them
a Pious Muslim will believe that we are
here tonight because Allah has kept us
from knowing the truth now what kind of
a just or loving God would do that and I
I saw on his face he said he is just but
he was very clearly very troubled by
this now the Quran also says in chapter
5: 101 don't ask
questions a lot of people have lost
their faith by asking questions it
actually says that chapter 5 ver 101 and
102 and so Muslims are discouraged from
critical thought but if you can move
them to critical thought about things
like that then Islam falls
apart and it has happened it does happen
but you need in the first place
everything Joel said you need to
establish a relationship you need to
establish a certain sense of trust
before you can even get there you can't
just come in and open the Quran and say
these things they'll just say that
you're a hate mongering bigot like
Spencer uh I'm going to uh risk being
Politically Incorrect like my president
Donald Trump president Trump yes
president Trump um I understand that
under Mr
Obama uh that the White House um before
the swamp was cleaned up had uh SW is
still there and still SW that's part of
this question is is I understand there
were quite a few Muslims in high
positions and still are I know president
Trump is selecting his cabinet now and I
don't know to what extent that goes
throughout the White House and the
administration I do uh understand that I
think Mr Obama allowed um five times a
prayer daily in the White House a lot of
his staff is Muslim it's been said that
his Muslim ties are extensive and I'm um
I wonder if you might address will
Donald Trump be able to have for
instance could he have prayer
Bible studies in the white house or is
that not allowed uh obviously Mr Obama
was allowed to have his uh prayer to the
east five times a day a quiet time for
the White House do you know anything
would well in the first place I have to
say that all the reports that I have
seen about Obama having a an Islamic
prayer room and prayer five times a day
in the White House are not from actual
reliable sources now I'm not saying
saying that they're not true I have not
been in the white house I don't know
what's in there I know that Obama
clearly had great respect for Islam but
even aside from the question of whether
he did that there there certainly is
prayer on Capitol Hill Islamic prayer on
Capitol Hill uh there's a very
interesting PBS or BBC I think it was
BBC biography of Muhammad it came out
right after 911 to whitewash Islam and
in the course of it you should watch
it's on YouTube it's fascinating it's a
total whitewash but there's just one
little scene where they're following
around this Congressional staffer who's
a Muslim he works for a congressman and
he's a Muslim and they're showing how
he's a Pious and devout Muslim working
on Capitol Hill in Congress in the Capal
and they go to Islamic prayer at the
capital and in the room are Ibrahim
Hooper and nihad Awad at the Council on
American Islamic relations Randall Royer
who was also with Care at the time who
was now in prison for Jihad Terror
plotting and several other prominent
Muslims and you can see them they're not
identified in the show but if you know
who they are you see them in the crowd
and then the camera pans back to show
who is preaching who's the Imam at this
prayer on Capitol Hill and it's anir
alaki wow and it's right there they
don't know who he is because he wasn't
notorious yet he's Pro he was actually
called a moderate Imam right around that
time in the New York Times and so this
is a if in case anybody doesn't know on
was a mastermind of jihad Terror
plotting he was in touch with some of
the 9/11 plotters with nidal Malik
Hassan the Fort Hood Shooter with Abdul
Faruk Abdul mutal who tried to blow up
an airplane over Detroit on Christmas
Day 2008 I think it was and uh maybe
nine in any case he was in touch with
many Jihad plotters he was killed in a
drone strike uh but I'm getting I I I
don't mean to get off track the point is
is that I'm not sure of that story about
Obama in the white house but there's no
doubt that there's tremendous
infiltration and that there are many
people taken as moderate Muslims who are
very influential in the White House in
the capital all over the US government
the Islamic Society of North America and
the Council on American Islamic
relations are both groups with
demonstrable ties established by the
justice department to Hamas and the
Muslim Brotherhood the Obama
Administration last year met 325 times
in the last year with representatives of
care even though it has been
listed excuse me listed as an unindicted
co-conspirator in a Hamas Terror funding
trial and all has all these other ties
to Hamas and the Muslim Brotherhood he
met with them almost every day last year
and that's just one example so this is
something that very much needs to be
addressed and needs to be fixed one
other thing that may even be more
important is that uh one one of the
things I used to do way back when I was
a young man is train FBI agents and
military personnel on the teachings of
Islam I would go in periodically to FBI
offices joint terrorism task force
military bases
and have a Quran study and teach them
the Quran and teach them about the life
of Muhammad because you have to you
can't un defeat an enemy you don't
understand you cannot defeat an enemy
unless you have a full awareness of his
beliefs his goals his motives how he
intends to achieve his goals all that
you can't do it but it's been official
policy of the Obama Administration since
November 2011 to
forbid any investigation or exploration
of Islam and Jihad in connection with
counterterror in on October 19th 2011 57
Muslim and Allied organizations wrote to
John Brennan the head of the former head
of the CIA the former head of the CIA
and he was actually in homeland security
department at that time and they
demanded that I be fired as a trainer
and that all mention of Islam and Jihad
be scrubbed from counterterror training
and he immediately
agreed and since then it is been the
official policy of the Obama
Administration that there is no mention
of Islam and Jihad in connection with
Terror Islam is a religion of Peace
Jihad has nothing to do with terrorism
it's a peaceful interior struggle and
this has been the policy upon which
US this has been the belief upon which
US policy has been based that all has to
be cleared out oh and president Trump
actually did it the other day said it
was going to happen he said that he's
going to recast the countering violent
extremism program which was Obama's
euphemistic counterterror operation as
countering Islamic extremism and of
course there's a huge uproar in all
these people talking about white
supremacists and everything but there've
been 30,000 Jihad attacks worldwide
since 9/11 how many white supremacist
attacks have there been I mean it's a
silly comparison but the reality is is
that in doing that President Trump is
just actually trying to drain the swamp
and turn this around so that we can
actually deal with the Enemy ideology
understand it and thereby be able to
counter it more effectively so it is
starting but there is a great deal that
needs to be
done um I just you know the real briefly
there was a very uh deliberate shift in
sort of I mean when OB actually almost
sort of began a little bit under Bush
but really when Obama came there was a
very deliberate shift in terms of um
American foreign policy where previously
we we were happy with the status quo of
these various sort of Third Rate
autocrats and suddenly we said you know
we can't be a legitimate democracy and
support democracy by propping up these
dictators um we will now be begin uh
relating to more moderate Islamic
regimes and so thus began you
know the Arab Spring uh sort of blows up
and there was a very deliberate effort
on our part I believe um to remove a lot
of these various leaders so of course
you know Mubarak Gaddafi and then the
effort through Benghazi Etc was to get
Assad out and to put the Muslim
Brotherhood in and they were treated as
though this was a moderate
uh you know group that we can relate to
and um so from what I just saw the other
day I mean Trump said we're going to
declare the Muslim Brotherhood a
terrorist organization I mean this is a
pretty radical turnover but even to the
point where you go okay well so maybe
we'll relate to the Muslim Brotherhood
uh you know in Egypt or something but
not not only that but they were bringing
well-known Brotherhood uh members into
government what was the name of the
fellow at DHS that was I mean he was put
in charge
um uh GH something what's that J Johnson
no he was the guy on his Twitter account
his his Twitter image was the Rabia sign
Muhammad alari yeah yeah yeah he he
blocked me within my first week on
Twitter but uh anyway yeah he's a lovely
guy but you know so thank God something
happened and he was removed but I think
it I think it got even too much for
Obama I mean the guy was yeah he
overstepped he he was Distributing
classified information and uh all sorts
of things but he was an open supporter
of the Muslim Brotherhood very high up
in the Department of Homeland Security
he's just one there are plenty others
excuse me yeah so I mean forget bringing
the fox into the chicken coop I mean
you're bringing in the what's a better
analogy gain of foxes yeah the mother of
all
foxes the thing about the de Declaration
of the Muslim Brotherhood as a terrorist
organization which very much need very
much needs to happen is that it would
also be a staggering blow Maybe a death
blow to the Muslim Brotherhood linked
organizations in the United States
notably care and isna and care and isna
are incredibly malignant incredibly
dangerous devastating forces they have
resisted every counterterror measure
that's ever been proposed or implemented
and they have propagated this idea that
resisting Jihad terror is bigoted and
islamophobic and racist you know I mean
I'm used to it I'm I'm I'm My Name Is
Mud and my character has been
assassinated more times than Rasputin
you know I'm I'm dead that's that's the
way it is but the worst part of it is is
that people who are ordinary American
citizens are afraid to do something
about this because they're afraid that
it's racist and that's because of K and
isna there was a plot that was actually
foiled a few years back a plot at Fort
Dicks where these Muslims were going to
go in and shoot the place up kill as
many American soldiers as possible
before they themselves were killed and
it was foiled when they took their gory
Jihad videos to a video store and they
asked the clerk to transfer them from
VHS to
DVD and he saw what was on the tapes and
he was very very disturbed and he went
to his boss and he said dude there's
some terrible things on these tapes
should I go to the police or would that
be
racist now the idea that even crossed
his mind that it would be racist to
oppose bloody Jihad Mass murderers shows
the Insidious influence of groups like K
and isna luckily he decided to be a
racist and the plot was foiled but there
are many many others who you know the
the the lovely couple Sayad riswan
faruko and tashin Malik the uh Muslim
married couple who killed 15 people in
San Bernardino in December 2015 there
was all sorts of suspicious activity in
their neighborhood and people going and
coming in the middle of the night and
they asked the Neighbors after the
shooting why didn't you call the police
same answer they didn't want to appear
racist a bunch of Muslims doing stuff in
the middle of the night that look
suspicious that would be islamophobic to
say anything about that's care that's
isna that's what they
do uh first I want to ask you um will
you reann nowc um where we can find this
presentation uh so that we can share
this with our Network um and I had a few
other
questions this
presentation uh once it
is whatever they do to those things I
will put it up at my YouTube uh Channel
which is Jihad watch video or Jihad
watch TV I forget one of those but it's
Jihad
watchchad watch.org as soon as I have it
and
uh in any case look quickly because
there are at least 10 posts there every
day and so things go right off the front
page the best thing to do is just read
the site every
day I will you also address um Sharia
finance and when you talk about coming
out of the cave I'm wondering um James
peroff wrote the book truth is a lonely
Warrior and Dr stanmont Teeth wrote the
book Brotherhood of darkness which
indicate that there is
the I'll just call it the sociopathic
Freemason uh organization that has been
around for centuries to undermine
civilization we'll say or to lead
civilization into a one one world kind
of effort and to
undermine um a a free Society so so I'm
my real question is if we want to come
out of the cave we have to acknowledge
this effort and also to
say to to inform others that there is
something to undermine through our
political process um I'm not I'm not
sure how to address it really I just
know that it's there and if we don't
know about it um but as important is the
Sharia finance that exists in in the
country right now well Sharia Finance is
something I know a little bit about um I
don't know anything about the other
thing I've heard over the years that
there is some shadowy Global movement of
globalization I don't know that may be
true I do not know uh the nature of
secret societies is that they're secret
and that means that there can not only
it's difficult to know what they're
about but also there are a whole lot of
speculation that might be baseless about
what they're about one thing I do know
in that regard is that certainly the
Socialist imperative which which is
dominant in Western politics these days
even though it's not usually identified
as such is a globalist internationalist
movement the idea is to erase to to
establish equality and they do it by
their procrustean bed and so all
distinctions among people have to be
erased and that means that's one of the
reasons why this immigration influx is
being so indefatigably supported by the
left because they want to eras
all distinctions between people and make
it so that every city is essentially
economically and demographically the
same as every other city and then there
will be peace because what will be the
point of having a war every place will
be just as squalid dirty and dangerous
as every other place and so everything
will be great there will be peace that's
the globalist imperative as I see it and
that's the only one I really know about
or am competent to speak about as far as
Sharia Finance
goes Sharia is an all- enping
all-encompassing system there is no
aspect of human life there is not one
single thing you can think of doing as a
human being that Islam doesn't have laws
for and they boast about this they say
Christianity just gives you some vague
moral pre precepts don't kill don't
commit adultery don't steal Islam gives
you a rule for everything so you always
know what to do which of course is also
in a certain sense destructive of the
human spirit
and in in its economic laws it forbids
Usery and usury of course is taking
money at interest and so the whole
Western banking system is illegal under
Islamic law and so Western Bankers
seeing a market that they're missing and
wanting to make money they have
introduced Sharia Finance into the west
where there is Sharia compliant banking
that's readily available in in the US
and in Europe and you can get you can
buy a house without any interest and you
can get interest free loans and so on so
as nothing violates Islamic law now the
the two worst aspects of this is that it
is one more accommodation of Islamic law
in the west and Islamic law covers
everything remember so once you
establish the precedent that Islamic law
is something that ought to be
accommodated where do you
stop where do you say well that much
Sharia is okay but no more you guys
can't bring that part of sharia in and
then they'll say why not you let us have
Sharia Finance you let us extinguish the
freedom of speech and Destroy criticism
of Islam and criminalize it so why can't
we do stoning adulterers why can't we do
amputating the hands of Thieves etc etc
why can't we make women wear the cloth
coffin why
not and
so the problem with is one of
accommodation and of the slope that that
leads to in terms of adopting all of
sharia eventually also in a practical
sense these banks are very stupid in
having these Sharia Finance boards that
are made up of imams and the imams are
generally connected with groups like K
and isna and so they're letting in
people with ties to Hamas and the Muslim
Brotherhood into their highest
leadership which is something that they
will probably regret one day
I just wanted to clarify something that
happened in gu
katif uh gush katif was it couldn't be
sustained Israel has limited
resources and there were 8 or 9,000
troops that had to be maintained there
continually and so it was used as a uh
PR as well as uh it was like the Sinai
we we conquered the Sinai but there was
no way to to maintain it and so we gave
it back as a gesture gush katif although
it was extraordinarily successful and
somewhere in the neighborhood of 20% of
Israel's
GMP um it just couldn't be sustained the
amount of effort the troops that had to
be there to protect them and I
I I listened to Joel this morning and I
and I listened to Joel this evening
the only way that I've seen and we have
seen a great deal of
success is is the love of Messiah That
Conquers that fear we have a brother
here tonight who went over to North
Africa Sierra Leon to uh work with
ebola he ended up preaching there he
ended up leading excess of
300 Muslims to the Lord that night they
saw the effort of people outside their
own and they were drawn by the love of
Messiah and I just wanted to affirm what
Jo was saying
that the superiority of love over fear
and hate is what draws people it's what
draw drew me I'm sure what Drew many of
the people in this room and that's all I
want there just one note about G katif
that I'd like to add to that you you're
no doubt exactly right and it was and
sustainable at least at this
time if it had been framed as such as a
tactical
necessity then I think there would have
been no problem military
tactics uh can make for some hard
choices for the long-term good the
problem with it was that it was nearly
universally framed as far as I saw as
something that would bring about peace
based on the assumption that the
Palestinians just needed a little bit of
land and if the Israelis made this
concession then peace would ensue PR
yeah and that is very damaging kind of
PR because it establishes a precedent
that if Israel just makes more
concessions gives up the settlements
gives up East Jerusalem the Temple Mount
whatever Jerusalem goes back to the way
it was before
1967 then there will be peace there
won't be peace if Israel does all that
any more than there was after Gaza for
the same reason the Jihad imperative is
maximalist I I agree but like I say it
there was no Bridge understood Island
and to get there there were nothing but
sniper attacks
Etc tactically it may have been exactly
the right thing to do and the only thing
to do but then it should have been
presented just as such I agree yeah it's
the same thing with um you know of it's
very popular today to um with for
Christians to engage Muslims in what
they call Interfaith
dialogue and um it's funny how the
concessions are always exclusive like
you get all these Christians to get
together they're so proud that they are
sitting there with some imams they go
hey look I'm engaging and you know this
sort of thing but inevitably it always
ends up with the Christians making all
kinds of concessions and the Muslims
never budge a single inch you go okay so
we just gathered together but you know
the the Christian Pastor said well we
worship the same God you know or they
they refer to Muhammad as the prophet or
you know whatever it might be there's
always some joint declaration and it's
always a compromise of some of the
essentials on the Christians part why
it's the same thing the the there's and
then they and then they say we need to
get together if you guys want to prove
that you're actually tolerant and loving
and so forth we're going to get together
again and then they do it again and the
Christians the Christians give in a bit
more and so it's the the same thing in
the political arena with Israel as it is
with the church and um you know it's it
always ends up with the uh you know we
we all get together and hold hands and
look how magnanimous we are and sing
K all right you got it this Interfaith
dialog just just a note about the
Interfaith dialogue it's it's really a
very pernicious thing and
uh you know it's funny we were talking
Joel and I were talking in the car
earlier about uh uh Protestant pmic
against the Catholic Church saying that
the Catholic church is the great Harlot
of the Book of Revelation or the whr of
Babylon and I always used to think that
was very silly but then came Pope
Francis now I realize they were right
all along um but in seriously though the
dialogue is an extraordinarily
self-defeating thing and two incidents
actually from the UK very recent
incidents indicate that uh in the uh
Scottish Episcopal Church which is not
very large um the uh the CH the
established church in Scotland um they
uh actually in the cathedral in
Glasgow for Christmas had a Muslim read
from the Quran chapter 19 and the Quran
in chapter 19 is describing the Virgin
birth but it ends up with this verse uh
this is Jesus the son of Mary and this
is the truth about him concerning which
they are in doubt that's the Christians
it does not befit Allah to take for
himself a son glory be to him when he
decrees a thing he only says be and it
is it's chapter 19: 34 and 35 now that
was read out in the Glasgow Cathedral a
denial of Jesus as the Son of God so a
denial of a core element of the
Christian
faith was read out in a Christian Church
how many times do you think that
Christians have gone into mosques
anywhere in the world and read about the
son of God being born absolutely none
the concessions are as Joel said always
on the Christian side not only that but
the Queen's
chaplain uh I believe his name is uh
ashendon anyway he uh spoke out against
this and received a storm of criticism
and abuse and was forced to
resign and not long after that another
cathedral in Britain not only read from
the Quran but had the Islamic call to
prayer the Islamic called to prayer
right there from the altar now let me
tell you something in May on May 29th
1453 the greatest grandest Church the
greatest cathedral in the whole
Christian world the AIA Sophia in
Constantinople was conquered and turned
into a mosque how is it turned into a
mosque the invading armies the Muslim
armies that had conquered Constantinople
that
day mechet the Conqueror the sultan the
califf went into the church with a muine
the guy who calls the Muslims to prayer
and he went up onto the into the pulpit
and he proclaim the Islamic call to
prayer and that made the church a mosque
so do if you don't think that there are
Muslims all over Britain now who believe
that the cathedral where that call to
prayer took place is now a mosque you're
naive and they will come back and claim
it eventually in the meantime the call
to prayer includes the first chapter of
the Quran the fatia which concludes with
this these words guide us to the
straight path the path of those who have
earned your favor not the path of those
who have earned your anger or the path
of those who've gone astray and univers
almost universally Islamic exites
explain that the path of those who have
earned your anger is the Jews and the
path of those who have gone astray are
the Christians so the Christians and
Jews were cursed from the altar of a
Christian Cathedral in a Christian
supposedly Christian country in the name
of dialogue this is what dialogue is
about I want to thank you for giving us
an amazing history lesson tonight thank
you but I'm going to ask you to be a
chess master and look several steps
ahead I was always terrible at
chess okay
Checkers
okay um I I have been somewhat
pessimistic in in the latest years I
have said there will be a day when we in
America as one will stand up and say we
can no longer allow these people to be
among us and on that day it will be too
late now I don't want to be there show
me an Exit Plan what are their next
steps and what should ours
be their next steps are quite clear
because they've followed the same path
in
Europe as Joel said earlier we're 20
years behind but it's coming that there
are areas of Europe where the
authorities don't even dare to go in
police and firemen don't dare to go in
and Islamic law essentially prevails
those area there will be areas like that
in the US it's already happened in
Dearborne Michigan you may know several
years ago there were some Christian
evangelists who went into an Arab
Festival it was an Arab Festival not a
Muslim festival and they were arrested
for preaching about Christianity which
is not illegal in the United States it's
illegal under Islamic law and that
happened in the United States now of
course the whole thing went to court and
the charges were dropped but the fact
that they were arrested at all in
Dearborn Michigan indicates that
Dearborn authorities are largely already
too far too much influenced by Sharia
than they ought to be we're going to see
a lot more of that not less unless of
course president Trump begins a massive
reversal of all this but ultimately they
will assert more and more of Islamic law
here and demand that it be accommodated
I was uh debating an Imam a few years
back at the University of Michigan in an
arbor and I went into the men's room and
there was a footbath in there for
Muslims to wash their feet before they
do the prayers
I looked around I didn't see any holy
water fonts I didn't see any Torah
Scrolls it was very strange it was this
public university had only made
accommodation for Islamic religious
practice and this kind of thing is get
sold under the banner of diversity and
so on there will be more and more of
that unless it is challenged and rebuked
and it
stops now what can we do in the short
term we can call upon these American
Muslim groups and they needs to be a
national movement to do this to
repudiate the aspects of Islam that are
incompatible with the Constitution we
constantly hear about the First
Amendment I'm constantly asked how can
you be saying this doesn't it violate
their first amendment rights if you move
to energetically against Jihad
absolutely not the first amendment is
not some kind of a license to commit
treason or sedition or subversion amen
the first amendment is designed to
protect the United States not destroy it
and if the Muslim groups in the United
States are preaching that the United
States Constitution needs to be replaced
by
Sharia and that women deserve fewer
rights than men and that non-muslims
need to be denied basic rights and that
disobedient women should be beaten and
so many other things in Islam that are
violations of American
law then they need to be prosecuted as
such and made it very clear that these
kinds of things will not be tolerated
here that they need to reform or these
things will be
prosecuted now nothing like this is
being done because it's all religious
freedom but I think religious freedom
ends where treason and subversion and
violation of America existing American
laws
begins yes and that they condemn they
say they condemn all the American Muslim
groups they say they condemn Al-Qaeda
and Isis and all the rest of them so let
them back up that condemnation with
action the know that there's not a
single mosque in the United States that
has a program to teach young Muslims why
they should reject the understanding of
Islam that Al-Qaeda offers why not if
they say they reject it why aren't they
trying to prevent young Muslims from
joining since there've been plenty of
American Muslims who have
joined so we need to see those kinds of
programs this is just a very short-term
practical measure but it could do a
tremendous good amount of good in
turning things
around I just you know in terms
of playing
chess I'm actually you know the past 20
years or so I've been incredibly
politically oriented um but it was
really eight years ago where I finally
just said I'm done you know I have no
confidence in the political process
whatsoever and um I literally I'll be
honest with you for the past 8 years I
didn't listen to a single speech uh that
the president gave because I just said I
can't for my own emotional well-being I
can't deal with this anymore and I just
completely abandon any hope in politics
whatsoever um well and so what I
essentially said is I said but you know
I don't believe in hopelessness and I
said I do believe I have a a a weapon in
my Arsenal at my disposal which is the
gospel and I'm going to focus on that
and I believe that one has you know
Eternal uh implications and it and it
can it can win I mean look at right now
Iran
20% growth of the church every year
fastest growing Church in the world Iran
20 years what Iran's gonna be a
Christian Nation we're going to be a
bunch bunch of transgender Sharia
laot um but um but now I go wait a
minute oh my goodness like I I'll be
honest I met Mike Pence a couple weeks
before the election I actually gave
talking about Bible studies in the white
I gave I shouldn't say this this on tape
um I gave him a copy of one of my books
I'll just say that um I didn't think the
guy was going to win I was just like oh
yeah meeting governor of vill you know I
was not like I'm going to meet in the
next vice president I just I just did
not believe this the whole we're just
this is so surreal and all a sudden I'm
like wait a minute maybe my cynicism my
complete pessimism was slightly
misplaced but again I still don't have
longterm faith in the political process
however that said I know it's but then
this but then this and on the other hand
and on the other hand but it's kind of
like in the scriptures where it says the
hand should not say to the eye hey I
don't need you my primar my I don't I
only have so much energy you know I know
I'm 45 but still I just I have energy
for the gospel that's what I'm primarily
going to focus on with the time that I
have but there are those that are called
to the political process and to give
themselves to that and it's necessary
that's not something we abandon as as
the the believing Community we need to
make that one of our priorities now our
overarching priority is the gospel cuz
that's going to have the longest you
know Eternal implications but we can't
abandon the political process and all of
the stuff that comes with that so we
need to have a comprehensive approach
again but we need to have our priorities
right uh in terms of the big picture the
political ultimately we can elect all
the wonderful politicians and we can
establish all the laws and and expect
all of these pagans to start
behaving but that's not how it works you
know you don't just put external laws on
people and suddenly they reform the
model of the Gospel is it transforms the
heart from the inside out if we actually
preach the gospel and do what we're
supposed to do then you get 10,000 new
converts they're going to start
naturally electing more righteous
leaders and embrace righteous laws you
know it's from the ground up and um you
know so we need to kind of understand
how this whole process works and get our
PR prorities right but it it has to be a
comprehensive approach the reality is
we're going to make three steps forward
we're going to go five steps back three
steps forward five steps back three
steps forward 10 steps back we all get
killed Jesus comes back establishes his
kingdom it's all good but that's that's
sort of
the that's sort of the longterm in the
interest of the both and rather than
either or approach I would actually uh
not contradicting anything Joel has said
that's all very true and wise and
important at the same time one other
thing to remember as well Egypt right
now is between 6 to 10% Christian when
the Muslims invaded in the 7th Century
it was 99% Christian where did all the
Christians go did they move away no they
converted to Islam they converted to
Islam over the years why because they
thought Muhammad was wonderful and the
Quran was eloquent and beautiful no they
converted to Islam because they were
subjugated under Islamic law made to pay
a tax made to live with various
humiliating and discriminatory
regulations and all they had to do to
get rid of all this aggravation and
oppression and suffering was convert to
Islam so most of them did over the years
and the remnant the 6 to 10% they are to
be commended and honored because of the
fact that they and their fathers and
their fathers and their mothers and
their grandmothers they have held out
for 14 centuries over a in in the midst
of an ongoing atmosphere of low-level
and sometimes high level persecution
it's a suffering Martyr Church and we
owe every bit of support that we can to
give it but the thing
is why did that
happen Egypt was part of the Byzantine
empire in the 7th century and the
Byzantine Empire had fought a series of
wars with the other great power in the
world the Persian Empire right at the
end of the 6th century and the beginning
of the 7th Century in other words right
before Islam and at the time of the
beginnings of what we know of as Islam I
think actually Islamic theology
developed later but that's another story
but the beginning of the Arab
conquests the Byzantine Empire nominally
ruled Egypt but did not have enough
troops to protect
it and so was completely overwhelmed by
the Arab armies if they had had a decent
Army in Egypt we might not be talking
about Islam
Today now that is not to
contradict anything about this is
spiritual warfare this is spiritual
warfare of the highest level and it has
to be met with spiritual
means but there is just as in the in
Incarnation the Lord is both Divine and
human there is a Divine and human aspect
to this and we need to make sure that we
do not suffer the fate of Egypt and
become a suffering Martyr Church that we
will be substantially reduced because
that is exactly what they want for us
and exactly what they are trying to
bring about and it would be armies that
could stop them just like the armies
that the Egyptian Christians wished they
had had at that time not only armies and
not armies without the spiritual aspect
but yes armies
too remember Churchill saying that we
can live easily and comfortably because
rough men stay awake at night and
protect us and we need a lot of those
rough men
now not the transgenders going into
Obama's
military there really the same thing
with Constantinople too is it's
incredibly sad and that you know there
been many efforts to take Constantinople
and they repeatedly failed and yes you
had sort of the development of gunpowder
and again the fullness of time but
really it was ultimately the EUR uh
the the the the CH the Christian nations
were so divided that they didn't send
any backup and you just had this sort of
struggling little group there to hold
the fort and and if if some uh western
or even Eastern European nations had
sent help they could have easily um cast
off mhmt and his crew but it was really
just a matter of a lack of uh Unity
among among remember the Council of
Florence the Council of Florence was an
ecumenical council of the church
designed to reunite the church reunite
that is the Catholic church in Rome with
the Orthodox Church in Constantinople
they had been in Schism with each other
uh for 400 years and it failed and that
was it failed definitively by about the
year
1438 and it was 15 years after that on
15 1453 that Constantinople fell and so
Joel is absolutely right the pop was not
willing or interested in calling a
crusade and sending troops over to
protect
Constantinople and so this is the fix
that we're in because of this kind of
disunity um first of all I want to say
thank you Joel for your answer saying
that
uh you believe that the gospel was the
answer answer um it's interesting I was
wanting to ask a question here and both
of you made answers that kind of
encouraged me to speak out now um You
Robert said uh that we needed more men
awake at night on their knees um the
verse that's been on my heart all night
is the one that says we warn not against
flesh and blood but against
principalities and powers in high places
so our war isn't really against the
human beings that are deceived by Islam
but it's against the principalities and
Powers um here again I say it's both and
not either or that's all right
um I'm extremely proud of the fact that
uh Pastor Yellen our pastor has uh
within the past few months uh started
having prayer meetings once a month um
even before the election and for people
that don't know um even before the
election Franklin Grant
went around the entire nation to every
major city having prayer revivals for
praying for the election before the
election need occurred and I'm a firm
believer that a lot of what's going on
is because of a lot of people
praying um and I hope we continue to
pray I'm a firm believer that the most
powerful weapon we have is
not anything other than prayer
absolutely I think an Hour of Prayer is
more power powerful than a month worth
of fighting and so saying all that um
I'm kind of asking you guys for wisdom
on how those of us that believe in the
power of
prayer
can direct those prayers and say the
right
prayers that will help bring Revival to
our nation because that's the only thing
that's going to save
us just pray in tongues
I tend to think that the Lord's Prayer
is the most effective prayer of all the
prayers because we pray that God's will
be done and we know that God is good we
know that God is Not Allah and so God
does wish good for us and it is human
beings who interfere with that being
accomplished so I think that the more
that we pray the Lord's Prayer and pray
in the spirit of the Lord's prayer that
is the best thing that we need at this
point uh yes again uh thank you very
much for your tremendous uh speeches
tonight on the other hand uh the thing
that concerns me the most is the Muslim
Community itself there's over a billion
or so Muslims in this world what are
they doing and why aren't they doing
something about what's happening I mean
this is their responsibility more than
it is ours ours is a defensive one
theirs should be their own you're
absolutely right but they're not doing
anything and you're absolutely right
about that I uh track that on Jihad
watch also uh there have been here and
there over the years various
demonstrations Muslims against Isis
Muslims against terrorism invariably
they attract 25 people 50
people tiny crowds
but on by
contrast when the cartoonists of
Muhammad were massacred in Paris in
January 2015 there were huge
demonstrations all over the world not
against the murders but against the
cartoonists 800,000 800,000 Muslims
demonstrated in Chia against drawing
Muhammad tens of thousands in Pakistan
Iran elsewhere we've never seen these
kinds of crowds in in anti-terror
demonstrations by Muslims the answer for
that is very simple the Quran teaches
Warfare violence hatred of the
unbelievers so when there are these
people who are warlike violent and hate
the unbelievers and they're Muslims and
you are a Muslim who doesn't hate
unbelievers and doesn't want to wage
Jihad but just wants to do your job and
take care of your family you're not
going to speak out against them because
you know they're right if you know your
religion you know that the book says
what they do is right and also that if
you complain about it you yourself could
be killed as a heretic or apostate and
so Muslims don't do anything they do
speak out sort of in the United States
all the major Muslim groups have
condemned the Jihadi groups and they
condemn every terror attack that happens
but what are they doing to stop them
nothing and they're not going to because
this is in the
religion I have for so many years now
sent 911 I see articles coming down the
pike every few weeks or even more
frequently it's time for moderate
Muslims to step up well really it's 15
years after 9911 you're still waiting
for
that get a
clue uh and so the the hope for in in
all that and there is hope is that Islam
is a totalitarian system and it does
have a death penalty for those who leave
and so it appears that there are a
billion
Muslims they're actually not or a
billion six they're are fewer than the
number that we have because there are
many hundreds of thousands maybe
millions of Muslims who are not really
Muslims but they go along and they don't
say anything but they are secretly
Christians or secretly atheists or
secretly something else and they are not
going to help the
Jihad now ultimately I'm not saying we
should put our hope hope in such people
but the strength of the Islamic world is
not really what it appears to be that's
all and so that is some reason for
hope we have a sister with a short
comment and then I think that's it for
tonight I just wanted to um mention Joel
you had said um that we have lost the
church has lost its
confidence in the message in the gospel
and I think the an the reason is is
because the church is asleep and is not
teaching it's not teaching what we need
to know people do not know how to answer
I think of Nabil Kishi who had in his
dorm room a a Christian who could answer
back the things that he spoke about
Islam and they're few and far between we
aren't teaching that's a huge thing
that's a very important I know we got to
stop but I'll be brief the churches in
general Protestant Catholic Orthodox I
don't know of any church that has any
kind of program to teach young people
how to counter dawa Islamic prizing and
yet Muslims are making concerted efforts
to convert Christian young people and
this is a grave Omission that has to be
addressed you look at some of the
highest Prof profile Muslims John Walker
Lind the the American who was found
fighting alongside Al-Qaeda and the
Taliban in Afghanistan and Adam gdan who
was very high up in al-Qaeda these were
people who were raised in nominally
Christian homes who were completely
susceptible to Islamic prosing every
young Christian ought to be able to
answer the Islamic arguments and that's
the responsibility of the churches that
they have tremendously failed to take up
the need
to yeah
absolutely what do you say we End by
praying The Lord's
Prayer that sound I'll just go ahead and
just read it and uh everyone can pray
out
loud I think I have the NIV that still
counts
right Our Father in heaven Hallowed Be
Your Name Your Kingdom Come your will be
done on Earth as it is in heaven give us
this day our daily bread and forgive us
our debts as we have forgiven our
debtors lead us not into temptation but
Deliver Us from the evil
one the kingdom and the power and the
glory forever and ever
amen all right
[Applause]